hello everyone and welcome back to the
norway chess 2021 uh we are going to
cover not one but two games in this
video because yesterday was such a great
day for chess all three games of
classical were just so impressive i
decided to maybe try out uh to show you
both games in one video as now you have
these little segments on youtube that
you can just click on them so if you're
interested in one game you can choose
that one if you want to check out the
other game you can choose the other one
but i know you guys will check out both
of them as that's the kind of kind of uh
you know people you are
uh so we're gonna start with uh tidy
versus carlson and then we're gonna
check out furuja versus nepo let's check
it out as there is quite a lot to cover
many awesome positive video moments and
many many great things that will happen
on the board
sotari with the white pieces opens with
e4 we have e5 by magnus knight f3
knights the c6 and now uh bishop to b5
going for the real lopez and the magnus
goes for a6 so no boring berlin we have
a morphe defense with bishop to f4 a4
knight to f6 and now castles and now
bishop to e7 so the the uh closed ruy
lopez we have rook to e1 and now b5 so
already i know you guys are wondering
will this be a marshall attack or not
well bishop to b3 magnus castles and now
uh tarry boldly plays c3 and he played
it instantly pretty much as soon as
magnus castled uh saying that uh i'm up
for a marshall are you up for a marshall
and magnus was like
and well just because toddy played it so
quickly and uh
you did discussed it quite a lot on the
stream yeah she said that if if you know
what you're doing you have nothing to
worry about but there's so much to know
and so much to learn about the martial
attack that uh well no no one is safe
there and the magnus maybe doesn't want
to gamble all that much with black but
he still finds a way to get some
activity he plays knight to a5 puts
pressure on tarry's bishop bishop back
to c2 and now d5 asking are you maybe
interested in going to some sort of a
weird martial situation for example if
he captures on d5 now we don't play the
usual martial stuff but we play e4 and
this is where black would really uh get
some advantage because you move the
knight and then
black just recaptures the pawn or if you
accept this pawn then you have to give
up the light square bishop and this is
something you don't want to do for
example knight captures rook capture
bishop bishop b7 and yes you are up
material but uh black has the bishop
pair and well this slides where bishop
black has is just a monster so tari not
interested in this he opens up with d4
and now d captures an e4 we have knight
captures on e5 and now there is a game
that magnus already played in this
position he had it against mvl in the
opera euro rapid this year and the game
ended in the draw magnus continued with
bishop to b7 but here we have c5 by
magnus and it is now as of movie 11 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see how do you continue capturing an e4
still not recommended it's pretty much
the same thing only now black
immediately gets this beautiful diagonal
for his bishop and maybe not something
you wanna
uh you wanna you know
uh do uh even though it seems like an
active position for white it's it's
really not the the bishop pair will be
just too strong so instead after c5 we
have bishop to e3 starting continues
developing and now bishop to b7 uh we
have knights to b2 and now magnus plays
rook to c8 so bringing the rook to the c
file that might soon open up we have h3
asking what do you play here magnus sort
of a waiting move here but also taking
away the g4 square from black's pieces
and magnus spent some half an hour here
uh considering
a lot of very cool stuff does he want to
play b or does he want to play queen c7
does he want to play whatever but in the
end he decided for rook to e8 and in an
interview after the game he said that i
thought of rook the e8 uh like it's the
first move that popped into my mind the
first minute i was considering the
position but i only played it after you
know spending half an hour here which is
how you play good classical chess so
here uh we have knight to g4 trying to
get the black knight to capture so you
can activate your queen with queen
captures on g4 but now knight to d5 by
magnus and here uh there's a it's
basically a whole mess here and it's a
question do you want to capture on e4 is
this spawn capturable or not uh well
tary decides that it most certainly is
he plays the bishop captures on e4
knight captures an e3 we have knight
captures on e3 and now c captures on d4
attacking the knight here asking do you
want to capture on b7 but then i capture
on e3 so first we have c captures on d4
bishop captures sunny for knight
captures and now bishop to b4 attacking
the rook so after this capture fest uh
has finished uh we now have this
position where tari is up upon and it's
a very dangerous pass point it's passed
deep on but magnus uh did gain some
activity both of his rooks are already
nicely placed on open files the bishop
is here very nicely um i enter the game
with tempo the knight is coming to c4 so
you know good things might happen but
still this pawn i mean you've seen what
happened in the rapper game when the
d-pawn started marching forward okay it
shifted to a c pawn but still uh so
knight back to c3 blocking this uh and
now comes carlson's idea rook captures
on c3 that's the stuff uh b captures in
c3 we win back our pawn with an attack
on both rooks and now after rook to e2
we pick up the rook on a1 queen captures
on a1 and now knight to c4 making it
impossible for white to trade knights
because the rook would hang on e2 so
queen back to e1 and now knight to d6
nothing blockades a pass pawn like like
a knight
we have knight to d5 offering a rook
trade and magnus obliges with rook
captures queen captures and now king to
f8 you don't want your to have your king
here you know behind all of these pawns
if the queen moves uh could become very
very uncomfortable for example if queen
here you can pick up the queen just the
knight to the e7 check picks up the
queen so king f8 gets rid of all of
these annoying threats and not knight
back to e3 so uh now keeping an eye on
the f5 square but also if the black
knight moves you can also just shift
your own knight to
f5 and now the material is completely
equal both players the queen and the
pair and the knight
but uh white has a pass deep on but
magnus has a two to one advantage on the
queen side and if he can start pushing
those pawns forward he could create very
easily a pawn of his own
a past pawn so g6 by magnus and now
queen to f3 uh we have king to g7 now
comes queen to d5 so slowly but surely
grabbing more space here queen to f6 and
now what do you play here well uh tari
could play something like queen to e5
magnus would trade queens and then we
get this position the knight just moves
and well it's a it's a position that you
do not want to have against magnus
because like we said this uh two pawns
could easily create a pass pawn and even
though this is uh this is a draw uh
magnus has no problem you know squeezing
that to draw all the way to win tari of
course knows this and he's not
interested in this queen to e5 move but
also it will diminish his own chances of
maybe winning the game so a3
uh and now comes queen to e6 magnus
again offers a queen trade but here it
would be even worse the trade because
now this pawn is nicely guarding this
pawn from advancing forward and again uh
this will be a problem uh as as soon as
that pass pawn is created so after queen
to e6 with queen to c5 and now knight
the e4 harassing the queen here uh and
also attacking the f2 pawn so maybe if
queen to f6 maybe you know a double
attack on the f2 and d4 pawns so we have
queen to c2 now putting pressure on the
knight but also defending the f2 pawn
and now h5 preparing h4 to really try
and stifle the white king
queen to d3
uh just saying all right what do you
play here you you can't start pushing
the pawns uh you you're going to lose
the b5 pawn uh what do you play magnus
goes back knight to d6
uh and what can tara do well he has to
wait and see what happens we have queen
to d2 now comes queen to f6 again
putting some pressure on this pawn here
maybe preparing knight here to
further
increase the the pressure on f2 we have
knight to d5 now attacking carlsen's
queen but not not moving the queen but
rather knight to c4 again saying i i
really want to trade here uh the queens
here but todd declines with queen to c3
and now queen to d6 attacking the knight
knight goes back knight to b4 putting
pressure on a6 uh but just a5 we have
knight to c2 and now you can't play b4
because of course the knight would hang
and the b4 square is sufficiently
defended but you can play a4 and now
imagine if everything gets traded off
the board there are no knights there are
no queens uh and b4 comes at some point
captures and you already have a
beautiful past apron that's very close
to queening so that's the idea so queen
to d3
and here we have h4 just grabbing more
space not allowing white anything uh
anything well good uh we have d5 pushing
that pawn you you want to push this pawn
at some point but you never really want
to push it because here it's safe on d5
who knows how safe it will be
queen to e5 by magnus as you can see the
queen is nicely covering the h2 square
but also now has access to many other
squares uh and it's a very hard position
to hold for white for example queen to
d1 is the one a very nice waiting move
that
that really does nothing for white but
it's a nice waiting move tari did not
want to play a nice winning move he
played knight to e3 he says all right
let's trade everything down uh and then
see what happens but this move
completely loses the game so feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
winning idea while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight captures an
e3 uh magnus did not play this uh so
congratulations to everyone who found
this but magnus tried a different idea
but it also includes knight captures on
e3 he first played queen to a1 with
check now he wants to check uh if tari
will block with the queen and then
queens get traded off and then he goes
into an end game which will be winning
for him of course as we said that if
everything gets traded off the board
then b4 and a3 are just winning for
black
but that he played king to h2 and now
magnus just repeated queen to e5 check
king to g1 and now he captured an e3 so
he wanted to check if he can win quicker
but then tari said no you can't you have
to win you know the the long way around
and then magnus just went back and then
traded on e3 so f captures an e3 and now
i don't even have to ask you to pause
the video because well you guys already
know what's happening and whenever
there's a b4 in the position and i ask
you to pause the video you guys always
figure out it's a b4 so here of course
magnus played b4 he creates a pass pawn
here regardless of what black plays you
can push you can capture and if pawn
captures you can just start advancing
your pawn for example if captures we can
play a3
well maybe not right away maybe we give
a queen to a1 check first and then after
king to h2 then play a3 and then d6
black is just much faster queen to e5
check now we're covering everything the
king is in check we're still covering
the a1 square king to g1 we're gonna
play a2 and after this it's just game
over we bring another queen into the
game with check that's it and it's even
you know just a very nice checkmate we
don't even have to play this
so uh instead after this b4 move uh we
have d6 right away by tari but now
magnus just plays queen to a1 with check
getting the same position so of course
if king back to h2 then we then we
capture but even if king to f2 we can
just capture b captures on a3 that he
gets the play pawn to d7 but it doesn't
matter there's queen to f6 with check
king has to move we have king to e2 but
now a2 and now what do you play here
well there's really no good move a1
queen is coming so your only hope is to
bring a queen into the game but magnus
has discovered queen captures queen
captures and now a1 queen the queen
another queen has been brought into the
game but now the other past a pawn is
also winning so here queen captures an
h4 by tari but now just a3 and he was in
this position on move 51 that arientari
resigned the game and another great uh
squeeze from magnus in what was
seemingly an equal endgame but no game
no end game is uh ever you know equal
it's only equal if you play perfect
moves so here the queen covers this
diagonal there's no way for the white
queen to deliver any checks to the black
king so you can just move the queen
anywhere alongside this diagonal and
then just advance your pawn to victory
that's it and of course tarry knows this
and here he resigned the game
now let's check out the other game
ferruccia versus nipple before we check
out the standings and what is really
happening after seven rounds of
incredible chess here in norway chess so
here we're shifting uh the the other
match firuja let me just check uh switch
this all right ferruja versus nipple uh
and uh let's start right away so uh
furuja also starts with e4 we have e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 but uh
uh alireza and nepo are you know two
uh two wild players they are not
interested in a boring rue lopez they go
for bishop to c4 he wants to play an
italian game a romantic opening where
good things might happen for both sides
so we here we have knight to f6 uh going
for the two knights defense and now d3
uh so the modern bishop's opening we
have bishop to c5 shifting into the joko
pianissimo and c3 now uh we have d6 and
now both players castle so this is
nothing new this has been played many
times rook to e1
where we often say that knight to g4
here is very useless because it doesn't
really do anything but i'm gonna repeat
it just so you guys know here we can
play rook to e2 and then we're going to
kick away the knight so nothing is
really happening here so after rook to
e1 we have a5 grabbing more space here
not allowing the usual a4b for chasing
the the version of b5 and so on uh we
have uh h3 preventing bishop to g4 and
now bishop back to a7 and here
uh interestingly nip already had the
disposition but he had it with the white
pieces against the grishok and grishok
won this game but here uh instead of
repeating knight to the a3 what nipple
played against grishok we have a4 and it
is now as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game uh so let's see how
how uh nipple continues with h6 and
knight b to d2 so the standard
relopaysian maneuvers we have bishop to
e6 uh challenging white's bishop here
and we have bishop captures f captures
now black has a nice semi-open f f file
for his rook but also that doubled pawn
will have nice support for whenever
black wants to execute d5
knight the c4 now putting pressure on e5
for example if you push d5 maybe e5 will
be weak but also just shifting the
knight to e3 and then you know who knows
where uh we have knights the h5 now
going for that newly created f4 uh
outpost and now bishop to e3 challenging
blacks bishop here bishop captures an e3
and now even rook captures this has been
um
in many lines proven to be better than
just recapturing with the knight as
you'll see also here so knight to f4
putting pressure on that g2 and h3
squares and now even the other knight
might join join the game somehow at some
point
we have knight c to d2 now uh sorry
knight c to d2 now the idea is shifting
this knight over to h2 and this knight
to f3 uh and now queen to f6 the like we
said df file is uh is a semi-open file
so we want to triple up here on the on
the f file knight to h2 and now uh you
could go for this somehow i mean it's
possible let's say knight captures rook
captures we're going to capture on f2
with checking h1 there's no way to
continue this and you you would just
have you know uh
wasted a piece for for nothing so after
knight h2 we have king to h at first by
nipple and now queen to f1 getting
another uh a piece here to defend but
also preparing g3 you need a defender
for that h3 pawn once g3 is played so
rook to f7 preparing to triple up on the
f file knight d to f3 now we have rook
eight
eight to f eight uh and now g3 finally
getting rid of this knight knight to h5
and now rook to d1
and now you can see that the dis
formation that nipple has here rook for
queen is very powerful uh a better known
formation is when the queen is behind
the rooks this is known as the alejand's
gun uh and uh well when the queen is
here you can just start capturing
something but when the two rooks are in
front of the queen maybe it's even
possible to sacrifice something at some
point uh so queen back to e7 now uh the
the queen is uh getting the e8 and this
knight is now coming into the game we
have king the g2 queen to e8 and now
rook to d2 so the other rook will also
help out
with the defense here but also with the
attack as you'll see
knight's the e7 now we have queen to d1
and now knight to g6 so what do you play
here uh well it's uh it's a question uh
the white queen is x-raying this knight
here but the black queen is also
x-raying this knight so you have to be
very careful here if you try something
like knight captures on e5 knight
captures and queen captures yes it seems
like you won a pawn but not really just
rook captures an f2 check captures
captures captures and then of course
queen captures and you've lost the queen
so uh careful of those uh x-rays uh and
uh so instead here we have just d4
striking in the center uh we have e
capture sunday for c captures and now
knight back to f6 uh we have queen to c2
uh putting more pressure on c7 that rook
is coming to c3 now and e5 now not
allowing white to push e5 so d captures
d captures and now rook to c3 as planned
going after this pawn so here nipple has
to decide does he want to advance the
pawn to c6 or does he want to play queen
to e7 maybe guarded this way so both
moves are kind of a small concession and
hippo decides to play c6 and now okay
there's no more worry about the try the
weak c7 pawn but now you've given up the
control of the d6 square sofiuja
immediately
lifts the rook up to d6 we rook the d7
yep we're trying to trade off the rooks
now rook c to d3 we have rook f to f7
now knight to f1 so now fearuja knows
that the rooks are probably getting
swapped off the board and if they don't
you know that's only in his favor so
it's time to get uh ready for this
knight to enter the game so rook
captures on d6 rook captures now rook to
d7 and furuji just trades captures
captures and now knight one to d2
and it's a question what do you play
here uh the knight is coming to c4 we
know this and uh black kinda has a weak
uh e pawn and the white also has a weak
e pawn so those are the things to
consider here but uh playing b5 right
away uh yes it seems great if captures
capture so we can continue pushing we're
gonna have two to one on the queen side
we can create a pass pawn the problem is
knight b3 attacks the a5 pawn and if
captures captures it's just very bad
there's a double attack on the c6 pawn
if c5 we can just go back knight to c4
and now we have two pawn islands whereas
black has four pawn island so it's going
to be much much harder for black to keep
an eye on all of his pawns so after
knight one to d2
knight to h5 is played now uh try going
for some uh you know very very cool
stuff here if uh you're not careful you
might run into it uh the idea is just
sacrificing the knight on f4 for example
if white carries up with knight to c4 we
can just play knight f4 check captures
check and then after the king moves you
have to go to g1 if you go to f1 then
it's over queen captures on h3 comes
with the check so we have to go to g1
and then we play queen captures an h3
threat and checkmate and the only way to
defend 91 and now we have this position
where white is up a piece but black has
a very nice repetition here just to
check here check here check here check
here check here and that's a draw by uh
you know perpetual checking so instead
after knight h5 uh ferugia doesn't allow
this of course he plays king to h2 now
this knight sacrifice would be pointless
because it doesn't come with check if
you play it we're just gonna capture it
and after knight captures uh you're not
in check white has nothing to worry
about you just move the knight defend
the pawn and that's it you're up a piece
so instead after king to h2 we have
knight to f6 uh and now comes queen to
c3 so uh piling up on that e5 pawn nepo
defends it and now king to g2 no more
worrying about that king
being in in range of this knight to f4
check we have c5 by nipple and now comes
queen to d3 again if you go uh knight to
c4 right away to attack the e5 pawn
three times then queen to c6 might be a
problem as the king is on g2 uh you also
are attacking this pawn twice so who
knows uh so after c5 queen to d3 first
uh and now knight to e7 yep is now
shifting the knight to c6 where it will
also defend the e5 pawn but also the a5
pawn so knight to c4 and now knight to
c6 and here everything is nicely
defended but firuja has one very
interesting move and that is queen to d6
he's asking do you want to trade queens
here if not i'm just going to start
grabbing some pawns and it's not easy to
accept this queen trade
because if captures captures now
your b7 pawn is hanging but also the e5
pawn is attacked once defended once but
also the threat is knight to f7 check
picking up the e5 pawn so you will not
be able to defend both of these pawns
and that's a problem uh and there's no
real really no good way to go about this
so nepo decides against the queen trade
or rather he offers the queen trade on
d7 now if the white queen captures then
the knight captures and the e5 pawn will
be defended twice but the e5 pawn is
already hanging so furuja just captures
it night f captures on e5 we have knight
captures on e5 and now queen captures on
e5 and now to not be down upon nipple
has to settle for capturing the a4 pawn
but now it seems like everything is
equal you know the position seems to be
equal material seems to be equal but
firuja is completely winning here but
you have to use some devilish trickery
to achieve this so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for furuja
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
c5 pawn is hanging whereas the e4 pawn
is not that's all there is to figure out
and if you found this then you truly are
a remarkable chess player
uh so congratulations to everyone who
spotted it and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's of course
queen captures on c5 and now first idea
is that the e4 pawn cannot be captured
because of this check king h7 queen that
uh f5 with check and now we pick up the
knight and that's it we defend our own
knight we're up a piece uh we don't care
if b5 trying to chase away the knight we
can just move the knight
defends our queen or we can just deliver
check we don't really care this is not
helping black
so after queen captures on c5 uh nipple
had to play queen to c2 now tries going
after the pawn this way but now just e5
that pawn is now a pass pawn and we're
gonna start pushing it and knights the
e4 although it looks really really
awesome attacks the queen puts more
pressure uh not there but on f2 uh the
problem is queen to f8 check and we just
again you know win the game very easily
king g8 knight here and uh black will
lose this knight there's no defense
so after e5 we have knight the g8 a sad
square for the knight but it has to be
done uh and now queen to d5 uh now the
knight can move we don't have to worry
about our queen being on c5 and we're
ready to start pushing our pawn
so queen to b3 pinning the knight again
maybe preparing b5 but the just e6
that's that's not a problem uh nipple
plays b5 he says all right now you move
the knight we trade queens my knight
nicely controls the e7 square but the
game is now again completely winning for
ferruccia but you have to find one more
move and it's not an easy move to find
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for white while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the e7 square is covered by the black
knight and we need to do something about
that and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's queen to a8
that's the good stuff you have to find
that the knight here can be given up and
if you found this then you
uh well there is no limit to your your
chess prowess uh so here if the knight
is captured we don't really gain
anything by this just e7 and there's no
stopping uh our advancement of the pawn
the knight cannot move of course the
knight is spinned and we are covering
the this diagonal so the black queen
cannot deliver any checks that's just
the game
so here after queen to a8 we have king
to h7 nepal has to move the king now he
has access to the e7 square but now
queen to e4 would check king to h8 and
now knight captures an a5 so that's
something you have to
uh you know allow
the queen is attacked so queen captures
on b2 but now e7 and there's no way to
stop the pawn from queening if you try
knight f6 we can just queen and you know
win this knight with checks so not a
problem so nipple decided to give up the
knight right away but now queen captures
an e7 and now nepal plays b4 you know we
always say that b4 can be surprisingly
winning in many situations but this is
not one such situation so queen to e8
check king h7 now queen to e4 with check
king h8 and now queen to d5
keeping around that b3 square not
allowing this pawn to advance any
further queen to a3 attacking the knight
now knight to b3 blocking the pawn so
queen to a4 and now knight to d4 so
advancing with the knight towards the
black king but still keeping an eye on
that b3 square knot allowing this pawn
to you know move an inch so queen to e8
but now comes queen to b7 by furuja and
he was in this position and move 57 that
yanni pomina resigned in the game and
firuja gets his uh much deserved victory
in the classical time format uh so here
you resign because uh your queen will
get overloaded uh your b for pawn is
attacked and once you defended then just
knight to f5 and now you can't keep an
eye on checkmate and also on the b for
pawn so the queen have to have would
have to defend against checkmate now you
pick up the b for pawn and now black has
no counter play whatsoever you're up a
piece up a pawn
and you have an easily winning game so
of course after queen to b7 uh nipple
resigned and a wonderful wonderful
victory for alireza ferrugia in this
round seven of the 2021 norway chess and
what does this mean for our standings
well let's check it out for the
standings this means uh
sorry my standings got cut off a little
bit for some reason uh
no idea oh yeah yeah i know what
happened yeah no worries i know what
happened there we go yeah there we go uh
so uh rapport's still leading as he won
a brilliant brilliant game you've seen
it in the previous video uh with 15 and
a half uh then uh followed by magnus
with 12 uh followed by nepo with nine
and a half then alireza firuja after
beating nepal now with nine sergey
karyakin within a half and arianthari in
last place with three points uh which is
going to be a great great round eight
because in round eight we have a clash
of leaders rapport will face magnus and
well now magnus will have the white
pieces and we're gonna see uh if rapport
can uh
you know keep delivering the way uh he's
been playing and maybe maybe even
achieve a win against magnus with the
black pieces but that would just be that
would be such a such an incredible uh
rating performance for our opera if he
could achieve this but we'll see you
know we don't want to jinx it or
anything but you know it is going to be
a great game so you know probably we we
are going to cover it so that's it hope
you enjoyed the first game and the
second game sorry about squeezing both
of the games in the same video but it
kind of felt like uh something that
needs to be done uh you know since both
of the games already finished uh
you have the little chapters there you
know you can just uh pick the one you
like but like i said i know you guys are
gonna check out both of them because you
can't get enough of chess
uh so yeah uh those are where the games
hope you guys enjoyed them uh i would
like to thank steven shirley new
stockade.com custom chess.com tom
darello and isaac his graph for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
amazing event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day